[Music]
howdy-ho rejected knows we go watch the
birdwatcher today most anticipated
reaction to 2018 oh yeah
are you excited I'm excited gods excited
Jesus is excited isn't that interesting
see at our patreon I don't know if you
guys have heard this not if you've heard
me say this I'm trying not to sound like
I'm on repeat here so I'm gonna add a
new flair to it okay at our patreon we
do TV show reactions for many of shows
that includes attack on Titan my hero
academia and Full Metal Alchemist
Brotherhood we also cover supernatural
Gotham and Riverdale we do weekly Q&A
and we do a music video coverage so
check out our patreon if you like to
become a patron just today and one of
our top reward tiers is whatever video
you request we must definitely do and
put up on the youtubes today comes from
doorbell Joe Floyd who was on the
channel last month he did a short film
called beyond deceived and JC
productions you could go check out his
channel yeah the key to a winning
personality is charisma I don't know
what this is but here it's awesome
[Music]
welcome said to restore your health
provide you with ultimate rank
it's from Spain [ __ ] off today we're
gonna be exploitable you will prosper
and what's the climax
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ] what here's copying birdwatcher
I'm sorry did you just compliment me by
calling me a birdwatcher that's right
you know
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
who is this guy he's a force of nature
that's surprisingly hilarious that hurt
and was I was describing the Marlin web
show yeah oh my god guys he's more from
this guy else on this channel from now
on Marlin web Bree
oh gosh I couldn't tell if that was
occasionally him just improvising with
is a sense of humor or if he actually
had a full-fledged character thought-out
like this guy's off as a birdwatcher but
really he's a perv who likes to have sex
with birds that was I think it's really
well done because it feels improvised
but also structured you know it feels
like he really came up with the
character that he knows really really
well and just is riffing based off that
kind of like that guy who plays the like
angry Satan nerd yeah same kind of thing
as the vibe I got off this and this was
like gut-busting and a disturbingly hey
I like to call this like blunt-force
comedy because it's just be pummeled by
one absurd idea save kind of like shot
back and forth throughout the whole
thing which is like pretty surprising
how it didn't get annoying is is there's
no time to think about anything else
it's just yeah he's just always up here
it's like really weird angle because
it's so it's like a wide shot so when he
gets close to the camera really is like
he's it's even like that just like when
somebody gets really close to your eye
there's like a little bit of distortion
like their nose is slightly bigger and
it's just oh he's pretty like a guy who
had like a real mental health condition
you know like what it
wouldn't ever make eye contact with the
camera whoa
[Music]
yeah his comedy skills are something
else like it's a very unique kind of
skill that he has in order for this bit
to work you need all of it to be working
hand in hand the camera movement the
right timing on the editing I like the
red and inserts he would come up with
like when I covered it to the plane
making noise the fact that he was like
actually on site like a lot of this seem
to be coming from him just improvising
with his like perverted jokes but
whatever's around yeah but also having a
full-fledged character hears jokes about
okay makes a living my kids are [ __ ]
starving
he doesn't make eye contact with the
camera seems like there's a really
specific type of mental health condition
he was kind of channeling here yeah it's
like there's so much like to the naked
eye it's just a bunch of random nonsense
but there's something about this weird
cousin yeah yeah cuz that was one of the
first things that grabbed me was the way
he's always looking like right up here
yeah and it was like I see blind but
he's not yeah off you know it almost
reminded me of like a really cracked out
version of an earnest movie yeah talking
to her and she just like his insatiable
energy and the weird things coming out
of his mouth it's like it's easy for
something like this to really out stay
it's welcome very fast yes somehow he
managed to keep this compelling the
entire time I was very much fascinated
that's that's a great character yeah I
watch a whole movie ruin this lady you
know for five or six minutes he's got a
great grip on sight-gags being physical
into it like yeah I think where he's
interacting with the girl I thought was
funny
but how his cameraman keeps undermining
its well-worn territory but you do it
well man's crisp jokes a job Marlon web
no hey Nobel thanks for requesting this
man you guys should check out Norville
he's not funny as Marlon but he is so
much hotter than Marlon mm-hmm
I met this guy in person he's like seven
foot eight yeah biceps little league is
my head rippling pecs yeah it's crazy
and he's ridiculously charming too
in fact he rested both of our heads on
each one of his pecs and bounced us and
I kept my hand him between his butt yeah
it was crazy crit broke one of your
fingers broke one of my fingers that's
how strong his glutes I've got a
powerful clinch you saying the the
gluten machine at the gym 400 pounds
each but dogs Wow that's 800 pounds for
a whole but some people are described as
clutch but I would describe Norville as
planted that straight yeah Hey look out
dudes
all right subscribe to the Marlon web
channel subscribe reject see you guys